PENALTY TIME WINDING DOWN AS
THE PUCK U U GOT ANOTHER PENALT
COMING U ON THE REBOUND!
A POWER PLAY TO PUT THE
PUCK IN THE BACK OF THE NET.
A TURNOVER A
ANGLE FOR E TRAVEL LIKE THAT HAE
JOHN COOPER AN
RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S THE SECOND TIME WE'VE
SEEN THAT.
NICE P7 SECONDS HERE.
IFD SISSONS.
>> ANOTHER CHANCE OFF A FACE-OF
12-11 IN PERIOD ONE AT HEDMAN
MOVES THE
REDMOND.
STAMKOS WORKS THE PUCK AROUND.
CARRIES IN DEEP.E WALL
AND WATCH KUCHEROV RIGHT
POWES FOR HEDMAN.
SHOTO HEDMAN, OVER
AND WATCH IN QUICKLY WRISTER TH.
BELLEMARE.AT'S GLOVED BY
FURST MAN TO THE PUCK.
FLIPS IT BACK OUT TO THE.
BIG TYPE SHOT IN FRONT OF THE
NET.' 99 SEASON.
>>
GETS IT AND DIRECT IT IS OVER
AND SLOWS ITS POWER PLAY
FOR TAMPA BAY, AS MEYERS RETUTL.
LOOKED LIKE HE KIND OF GOT I'S Y
WITH A LOT O1 TAMP
LOOKS IN THIS GAME, ESPECIALLY
HERE ON THIS POWERA
YOUNGSTER BY MATT DUCHENE.
KILLORN BACK
LEAD.
IT GOING TO BE FOOTE THAT FIND .
WHAT A PASRSBERG.
BACK OUT FOR JOSI.
FORSBERG, WHO HA